alors aujourd'hui je vous emmène dans
l'atelier de quelqu'un pour qui j'ai un
vrai coup de coeur
il s'appelle thomas henno ne vous le
connaissez sous d'autres cieux
c'est un orléanais il aurait voulu être
écrivain il aurait voulu être acteur de
théâtre mais c'est dans la pâture qu'il
s'est trouvé et c'est tant mieux
il nous reçoit chez lui en musique au
coeur même de son intimité puisque son
atelier a pris place au beau milieu du
salon familial des bandes de couleurs
par dizaines et des toiles récentes dont
l'exposition au théâtre il a travaillé
sans relâche des jours et surtout des
nuits entre euphorie et inquiétude il
espère s'être renouvelée cette fois là
qu'est ce qu'elle dit de toi ce qu'elle
dit de moi là c'est que elle va être au
théâtre et les traiter comme une
improvisation théâtrale et violente où
elle plutôt joyeuse ah bah ça c'est une
très bonne question j'espère qu'elle est
les deux le regard c'est la force de
cieux il peut passer des heures en moins
de contemplatif à scruter sa toile avant
d'y mettre sa patte
une couleur un pigment le geste est
précis ou non il adore les grands
classiques et cela se voit molière
shakespeare tchekhov son préféré
pour moi c'est c'est nina mais c'est
nina dans l'acte de même parce que je
trouve qu'elle revient plus forte
qu'elle est moins jeunes premières clés
qu'elle a gagné en maturité et en force
j'espère que ça soit dans le regard ce
qui m'a un tout petit peu éloigné du
théâtre c'est la passivité de l'exercice
c'est d'attendre que son téléphone sonne
c'est de dépendre de casting de tout ça
et j'ai alors je lui en veux pas mais la
peinture c'est plus direct
la peinture c'est un résultat tout de
suite on va à notre cadence et le
phénomène de création ne passe pas par
un intermédiaire écrit où il est direct
il est fulgurant eh eh oui c'est en ça
que la peinture me rend heureux
les mots le théâtre la vie la mort cieux
c'est un peu tout cela à la fois son
travail ne laisse jamais indifférent
il est exposé au théâtre pendant un mois
d'autres idées de sorties avec zaï zaï
zaï spectacle inspiré de la bande
dessinée culte de femmes carreau un road
movie sur fond d'urgence et fut de
flamber sécuritaire avec les excellente
comédienne adèle haenel et blanche garde
à vue
leave no trace en avant-première à
orléans et en présence de la
réalisatrice américaine de bras granik
le film nominé une dizaine de fois
raconte l'histoire d'une adolescente et
de son père qui vivent clandestinement
dans la forêt de solitaire à qui on
propose un toit une scolarité un travail
une nouvelle vie et des choix douloureux
forcément la musique au secours du
patrimoine ce soir l'ensemble baroque la
rêveuse donnent un concert au profit du
pavillon de musique du château de
meung-sur-loire pavillon qui tombe en
ruine
et on termine avec d'autres peintures un
autre style celui du loir et un daniel
casse par une peinture en mouvements de
grandes envolées de blanc de bleu de
jaune strié de noir une rétrospective
lumineuse l'oeuvre de toute une vie
[Musique]